you are a man of faith i'm a christian
and you are a man of science
what is the role of religion
and of science and society and
in the individual human mind and heart
like yours
well i was not a person of faith when i
was growing up i became a believer in my
20s
influenced
as a medical student by
a recognition that i hadn't really
thought through the issues
of
what's the meaning of life
why are we all here
what happens when you die
is there a god
science is not so helpful in answering
those questions so i had to look around
in other places and ultimately
came to my own conclusion that atheism
which is where i had been
was the least supportable of the choices
because it was the assertion of a
universal negative
which scientists aren't supposed to do
and agnosticism
came as an attractive option but felt a
little bit like a cop-out so i had to
keep going trying to figure out why do
believers actually believe this stuff
and came to realize it was all pretty
compelling that there's no proof i can't
prove to you or anybody else that god
exists but i can say it's pretty darn
plausible
and ultimately
what kind of god is it caused me to
search through various religions and see
well what a what do people think about
that
and to my surprise encountered the
person of jesus christ as unique in
every possible way and
answering a lot of the questions i
couldn't otherwise answer
and somewhat kicking and screaming
i became a christian
even though at the time
as a
medical student already interested in
genetics people predicted my head would
then explode because these were
incompatible world views
they really have not been for me
i am so fortunate i think that in a
given day
wrestling with an issue
it can have both the rigorous scientific
component and it can have the spiritual
component covet 19 is a great example
these vaccines are both an amazing
scientific achievement and an answer to
prayer
when i'm wrestling with vaccine
hesitancy and trying to figure out what
answers to come up with i get so
frustrated sometimes and i'm
comforted
by reassurances that god is aware of
that this is i don't have to do this
alone
um
so
i know there are people like your friend
sam harris
who feel differently uh sam wrote a
rather famous
op-ed in the new york times
when i was nominated as the nih director
saying
this is a terrible mistake
you can't no you can't
you can't have somebody who believes in
god running the nih he's just going to
completely ruin the place
you